hey guys my name is Jess McDonald eat is
a tenth of sep tember today and I have
all of the news for you alright gamespot
has all of the news I have three stories
that I promise you that really good
first up the xbox one is not exactly
selling like hotcakes in Japan unless
all of a sudden people weren't all that
keen on hotcakes and that's exactly what
it's selling like the first week sales
numbers are in and they're backing up
just how hard it is for Microsoft to get
a hold on the region within the first
four days workers up sold about 23,000
Xbox one's all up according to local
game publication for mitsui that's about
a third of what the xbox 360 was selling
during its initial release which
amounted to about 160,000 62,000 of
which was sold in just the first two
days comparatively so nice old 308,000
PS wars during their first week on
shelves while Nintendo shifted 322,000
we use how's the hand-held sony sold
325,000 PS Vita's in the first week in
the region and nintendo shifted its
entire 400,000 unit allotment of 3d s
consoles on launch day yep Japan sure do
love their handhelds next up destiny has
broken even since the notorious half a
billion dollars that went into the game
has been matched with 500 million bucks
worth of revenue Activision have
announced that the revenue has been
accrued from retailers or during the
game as well as business from first
parties whilst this makes destiny the
biggest new video game franchise launch
ever it's still beaten by existing
franchises like Grand Theft Auto 5 which
made about 800 million on its first day
activision's other major shruti series
made bank with over 1 billion in the
first 24 hours of call of duty ghosts
launching in other Microsoft e news it
seems the publisher is keen to buy
minecraft creator
J insiders told the Wall Street Journal
that the two companies are in serious
talks over the deal which would be
valued at over 2 billion and could be
signed as early as this week just last
year Mojang's co-founder calm na
suggested that they weren't interested
in being bought out saying we have more
money than we need for those of you
concerned that this deal would
jeopardize minecraft availability on
PlayStation sources have suggested that
the game will stay on rival products
comments made from anonymous people in
the know to Bloomberg also suggests that
Devan founder Markus Persson would
likely leave the company should the deal
go through although he was apparently
very involved in setting off the alleged
acquisition with xboxes still Spencer
ask your question of the day let me know
down in the comments if you think
Microsoft earning mojang will be a good
or a bad thing for Minecraft if you're
after more gaming things you can head to
gamespot where we've but uh since four
of you and our destiny review in
progress that is it for me today as
always thanks for tuning in and I will
catch you same time tomorrow